hello welcome to ed talks with khan
academy
i am excited today to talk to pedro de
broker and uh my apologies in advance
for not having the correct belgian
pronunciation of his name he is an
author who has authored a number of
books we're going to talk today about
urban myths about learning and education
and i'm excited to dive into what we
know from research that may
disprove or suggest we are wrong about
some of the things that we hold to be
true about learning and education
i will remind you that khan academy is a
non-profit organization and we are able
to do our work through
generous donations from folks like
yourself if you go to khan academy.org
donate
you will be able to contribute and help
keep us moving and working through and
doing all of the work that we do
so thank you for your consideration of
that we also want to thank a number of
organizations who've stepped up during
covet 19 to help support our work
including bank of america at t
google.org novartis fastly and general
motors
a reminder if you want to
get an audio version of this or any
other ed talk or a home room uh
we have those available in podcast
version homeroom with sound the podcast
is available wherever you get your
podcasts
so with that
uh we're going to talk today as i said
to the author of both of these books
urban myths about learning and education
and more urban myths about learning and
education
pedro thanks for joining us
thank you for having me good hello
hello
so the first question i like to ask
folks is to tell me a little bit about
how you got here how did you end up
writing books about learning and
education
well it's it's a funny story
i remember one evening
eight years ago nine years ago
and i was asked to
be the staedtler and waldorf in a kind
of education setting and my only job was
to give funny remarks so i thought great
um and
halfway during the second talk at a
certain point uh one of the speakers
was mentioning that we have a creative
brain have and a rational brain have and
i forgot that my mic was on
and i said oh no
my [ __ ] detector is now in the red
and everybody was watching what what did
you say
and and um
um
every time i still
when i meet that speaker i still
apologize for that moment
but he he said to the audience i have to
admit he's right he's correct
but afterwards a lot of people came over
to me and started asking but is this
correct or what about this and
i heard so many different myths that
said somebody should do something about
this and um i was working my phd had a
writer's block i have to admit at that
time and so i've been there
yeah
we all been there i guess and so i asked
i asked my publisher
can i write a little small book about
urban myths in education
and
that was the starting point now the book
has been translated in english chinese
turkish
spanish and and
and
it has traveled the whole world and i
have traveled the whole world talking
about this
and you managed to finish your phd
that's really impressive
yeah yeah yeah i don't know how i've
done that but i've done it yes
i understood so how did you gather all
of these different myths
well the first book
was pretty easy because we could look at
research with common myths and common
misunderstandings and actually um if we
followed the news just for one year we
already had a lot of them
yeah and after the first book we thought
maybe a bit naive that we were done
but when the first book was published we
received so many questions yeah but what
about this and what about that and could
you check this too and the second book
is just based on all questions received
for the years after the publication of
the first book
wow nice
so that was that yeah just raised all of
these questions for people just starting
to hear about it made them question
other things that seems like that's a
good outcome for the first book to make
people question more
yep correct so let's dive into a couple
of them
we talk a lot here about khan academy at
khan academy about the importance of
knowledge but there's this myth out
there that if you can
google something
do you really need to learn the
knowledge piece of it
how about that one what's your what's
your take
well
it sounds reasonable but the first
question is how can you
come up with the right words to google
if you don't know the subject
but the second element and that's more
painful is that
the algorithms of for instance google
they are not always aiming at
correct answers but more aiming on what
do they think you want to know
and sometimes this can be incorrect
that's one thing but also if you look at
information you are receiving and i'm
not talking only about fake news and
stuff like that but you have a lot of
people who have the same name
and so we have had in the past some very
uh
interesting uh discussions about famous
artists but then they were discussing
football player instead of the altered
artist
but there is another very important
option
important reason because
most of the time you have to come up
with an answer straight away you have to
know things to learn new things if
there's no prior knowledge you have
nothing to connect it to and so you
don't have the building blocks for the
next learning step
and and it's it's a bit of a quote i
once said but i think it sometimes it
sums up quite nicely on the internet you
don't find knowledge on the internet you
internet you find information but what
you need is the knowledge to fact check
and to understand that information
that all makes sense and i like that
knowledge versus information uh
distinction that's really interesting
and i know the other piece is when
you're solving more complex problems
sometimes you need that base knowledge
to solve them and if you have to stop
every time to go
google for that base knowledge you're
going to forget what you were doing
solving the complex problem while you're
trying to find the answer for the
base one is that
right
um
it's late in the evening over here and
one of my sons was just passing through
going to bed and and actually i remember
a very nice example of this
um a couple of years ago he had to learn
his tables of multiplication by heart
and he hated it and he asked me why do i
need this and then i went to a door and
i asked my son can you open this door
which he did
and he said now try to imagine you can't
remember how to open the door so every
time you are coming to a door you have
to try to open it try to figure it out
how you need to do this you buy on the
door you use the head for a second
okay
if it's open you can only hope for one
thing that there is no second door
because otherwise you will have to start
over and over and over again
now you have to learn the tables of
notification by heart and it takes a lot
of effort but pretty soon you'll need
much more complex
uh you will see much more complex
mathematics and if you need to calculate
your modifications at that time you will
lose
so much time and energy that's so you
won't be learning something new
that totally makes sense yes
uh
so
i think that that importance of
knowledge for all there's not just one
reason there's multiple reasons that
that you've laid out here why it's
important
uh makes sense all right
one of the most pervasive things you
talked about your detector going red
uh learning styles
uh
that to me it's so common and people
just it seems
so
attractive for people it's something to
believe that there's visual learners and
auditory learners and i hear it all the
time
uh
tell me your thoughts on that one
well um it was one of the very first
myths
that i encountered that put me on the
right track actually a couple of weeks
ago or months ago dan willingham was on
the show uh yes yeah yeah and it was one
of his videos that put me on track of
trying to figure out what about those
learning styles
and
what we've seen is a lot of people
recognize it and first of all it's true
a lot of people do have learning
preferences
maybe some people like to read or some
people like to listen but there is no
of no clear correlation between your
learning preference and better learning
but still that gut feeling
oh it's correct but i can flip that gut
feeling
just a question you have to ask yourself
as a teacher are you in favor of
pitching holding an education
no because we think all our pupils are
different our students are different
yeah but if you are using learning
styles you are pigeonholing your
students in three four the maximum
amount with mbti 16 holes 16 boxes
but our children are much much more
complex
yes yes and
it it always is the
when you look at the research there's
just no it's this isn't a case where oh
the research hasn't been done there's
been lots and lots of studies and they
just across all of them don't find
this effect and i wonder if there's
still there if there's something here
about
uh research versus my personal
experience that is causing this to be
persistent and that idea of people
having a preference
well there is something else also
happening in science for instance in
a lot of people uh write about education
and for instance an area that there is a
lot of research on is on computers and
learning
but those studies not often are being
done by psychologists so what we've seen
is a lot of research
for the past 10 20 years
done on computers in education
but mentioning learning styles not
checking if this theory is correct or
incorrect so you will find actually a
lot of research not really on
learning styles but mentioning learning
styles feeding all the people who think
they believe in but i've read it in a
study yeah but that study was not done
by psychologists knowing their stuff
they were done by computer scientists
they were done by educationalists
perfect people but they didn't know that
they were using that something is that
they were using something incorrect
right right that makes sense they almost
assumed that learning styles was a thing
before as an assumption of the work that
they were that they were doing yeah yeah
that makes sense
so in that world of computers and and
technology uh also a space that i'm
interested in
um and we hear a lot about ditch we hear
about a lot about digital natives and
that digital natives want something
really different with their education
and their system what does the research
say on that
well digital natives first was coined by
mark prensky in 2001 already and um
it was just based on a couple of
observations it was not based on actual
research and again it sounds logical
because if you give a device to one of
your children or your pupils or students
they are very handy with it but there
has been a lot of research and paul
kirschner myself we've done a
review on all the research since 2001
and what we've discovered is that
it's not true it's not the case you have
to make a distinction between
uh the content side and the strategic
side on one side and well the button
knowledge and it's true
young people young students are much
better in figuring out how some device
is working but if we are talking about
the content but also how to use it also
to know if something is correct or
incorrect
then we see that they are not that good
at all
actually if we look at 30 and 40 years
old they are much closer to what has
been described as digital natives than
10 year old 10 year old 20 year olds
ah interesting i hadn't known that that
piece of the the last part i remember
looking trying to find in mark penske's
book the research to support it but he
was basically coining a term
but without having necessarily the the
research to support it and it caught on
yeah and and there's a lot of research
and and and we've
we are
we keep checking all research because
maybe now it will change but we didn't
find any evidence yet and in different
different regions for instance in in
china or japan we can't find digital
natives we can't find them in europe we
can't find them in the united states so
sorry actually
it's a very important message because
um it's very important for us as
educators as teachers we need to train
our students
in how to
handle these devices how to work on the
internet how to handle the information
they are getting but also to know when
they can use their cell phone and when
it's better to put it away
i think that
the fact that there are no digital
natives gives us an extra task in
education
uh that the idea of digital digital
literacy and uh what that means is it's
so important but people have to be
taught it just like other skills yeah i
i guess so
yeah we have a question from uh from
facebook ahmad
says in today's digital world we have
knowledge but how can we solve problems
uh that
many students you know have degrees but
even then they get lost and so i think
that i'll ask a related question to this
we've we've talked a lot about kind of
myths of things we haven't found
what does work for learning and
particularly maybe problem solving to
get at most but
well
a lot of stuff works in education
actually
not everything works and nothing works
all of the time but there is a lot of
things we know that can do the job
and
we know that
basic knowledge
and and
arithmetics and
reading comprehension can help you a
long way
but then there's also the part of
problem solving we've seen uh for
instance from research like project
follow through but also from research by
the oecd with the visa results and
things like that that a base a good
solid basic knowledge can help you
and also can help you to solve problems
but then you get you need the
opportunity to get in touch with this
kind of problems and get
the hang of it so if you in education if
you have a good
basic knowledge if you have a lot
background knowledge can help you too
but also if you see a lot of examples
good examples of how problems are solved
if you get this not only in one topic
but in several topics maybe in
integrated topics but then also
give
you the opportunity to try
and fail but learn from the failures
then you'll get a long way
just like you have to learn how to
read a book how you to write a sentence
it's also important to learn how to
solve a problem
yes so
background knowledge practice
with feedback of whether it's right or
not
yes
and and
you know there's something that i want
to add because
when people are thinking that when
people know we are writing about urban
myths they often think it's black or
white
but we use three categories in our books
the first category is total nonsense
first for instance learning styles those
are no total nonsense if you are
discussing um some other topics like
multiple intelligences then we say it's
nuanced
and for some topics we have to say we
don't know because even in science there
are a lot of discussions
let's take the 21st century skills it's
topic that's also very popular and
closely related to problem solving
now there are two
discussions in the scientific world that
we don't have a solution yet
but that are really relevant for this
kind of discussions in education the
first
element we are not sure about is
is it actually
a skill or is it rather a personality
trait for instance creativity is it
something that you can learn or is
something you need to develop that's the
first point of discussion the second
point of discussion is how generic are
those skills because for instance i can
be very creative in playing the guitar
but it doesn't mean that i'm very
creative as for instance a plumber trust
me i'm not
so how generic are those skills and
we don't have the answer on these
questions yet
um but i do think they are very
important
to help us further in education
yeah so this idea that research
is evolving i think is an important one
and that we don't always have all the
answers but psychology itself recently
has been through quite a reckoning on
that some things that we
thought were true after trying to
replicate those findings we're seeing
aren't replicating so well so do you see
some of some of that pattern too
yeah
thank you for bringing this up actually
um eric erickson once described that
crisis means growth well if that's the
case psychology has been through a major
period of growth
the biggest period of growth in history
because it's true um
a lot of classic studies have been
replicated for the past 10 11 years and
failed
and uh there is new new book coming up
next year next summer uh the psychology
of great teaching and together with
kasper and lisa what we have tried to do
is trying to figure out what is still
standing
and what should be left
left behind and some of the big theories
for instance very popular and teacher
training piaget
is one of the victims
but on the other side there's also
great news because yes there's a lot of
stuff that wasn't able to uh being
replicated but there are also a lot of
things that are now standing stronger
than ever for instance if we look at
dual coding a lot of cognitive science
that has been used in education for the
past 10 15 years we have now a bigger
knowledge confirming scientific
knowledge confirming those insights
but great it has been
it has been a very strange period
it has it has so you just uh kind of
drop dual coding can you tell talk to
folks about dual coding if they're not
familiar with that
oh my sorry for that dual coding is the
idea that if you combine images and
words we have two channels in our
working memory a channel for words a
channel for images if you use them both
there is a bigger chance that will be
learned okay but wait if you um put too
much pressure on one of both
channels then you are getting less
learning for instance if there are too
much images if the images don't relate
to what what is being taught people will
learn less but also if you have words on
the screen
that are exactly the same of what is
being said then the word channel gets
overloaded and again
students will learn less
that that makes sense that it's not just
put all the information you can through
both channels there's nuance to it and
how to do it well and what that looks
like yeah i i think that's the biggest
task we have as scientists not telling
people
do this and miracles will happen
no
do this and maybe this will have an
effect and if it doesn't work please try
this because
um it's easy for gurus to say do this
and everything will better and you it
will even smell better but
in real life
it's much more complicated than that
can i give you an example
yes and it's it's it's it's connecting
several dots because we received a lot
of questions about growth mindset and
it's a topic in our second mid book but
also a topic in the psychology book
and
carol dweck
is not a guru and i can prove you she's
not a guru she's a real scientist
because a lot of the studies that were
performed on a growth mindset had a very
small group of students being involved
in the study
and for the past couple of years there
has been
real replication and
credit to carol dweck she also
participated in research on uh
replicating her original uh studies
and we found out that the effect of
growth mindset on average is not that
enormous well it's
really small
but the main word in my previous
sentence was on average
because we see that for some children
for some students it can even have a
negative effect to um stimulate a growth
mindset
but if the average is small or nothing
close to nothing and some p pupils have
a negative effect then it's not hard to
imagine that other students other pupils
can have a positive effect and we see
that for instance children from younger
children from a
more poor background they can benefit
from a growth mindset
approach so for us it's very important
not to say throw growth minds throw
growth mindset away but when will we use
it
for who will we use it but also keep an
eye on the effects because maybe in your
case it can have a perfect
splendid effect but maybe it's the
opposite and then it's you as a teacher
or educator or a team to say let's do
something else
yes so sarah sarah helm from youtube you
asked uh if if uh pedro could say
something about motivation myths so
there's a piece about uh mindset uh
mindset and how we think about
motivation from growth mindset that's i
think important
uh anything else on motivation
i i can't tell a lot about motivation
because
there's a lot of about it in the new
book but i give you two very interesting
insights
the first thing we often think about you
have or intrinsic motivation or
extrinsic motivation and intrinsic is
good and extrinsic is bad
but it's much much more complicated
um for instance there are a couple of
versions of extrinsic motivation and
i can give you again a very simple ex
example
you have a student who wants to become a
doctor
he or she is really motivated to become
a doctor
but he or she is not really into
mathematics but they know that student
knows that if i want to
become a doctor i really need this kind
of mathematics then that student isn't
motivated
intrinsically for mathematics but has a
good positive extrinsic motivation
please keep that kind of motivation
but also and this will surprise a lot of
you
we know that a lot of people think the
more passionate you are about the
subject the better
but there is
an issue with that because we know that
if you're really really passionate about
something but you don't have anything
else in your life
then
there is this bigger chance that when
you have whenever you get to into a
problem or hurdle that you will give up
if you have a passion but you also have
something on the side something else
another hobby
then you are more resilient for any kind
of setbacks you can
encounter trying to achieve your passion
so the idea of being more motivated or
more passionate is better it's again
much more complicated than that
yes
okay so this relates to a question from
alex morelli from youtube who says you
mentioned your son not liking to
memorize his multiplication tables
how important is student drive in
learning and i think there's a follow-up
question of if a student's not motivated
to do something how do you try to get
them to be motivated to do something
yeah yeah that's the one million dollar
question
all
first of all i think we have to accept
even us as a teacher we are not always
that motivated for every single part of
the things we are doing so that's
sometimes i treat myself with chocolate
to get through a task that i have to do
right now yeah you should come to
belgium the best chocolates in the world
i wasn't paid for that okay
but going back to the question
um
one of the things is we need to find um
that the experience a kind of success
uh so if it's too difficult or too easy
i think a first step is make sure that
everything is
a
possible challenge
it's a challenge but a challenge that
they can achieve you know the the
classic concept of scaffolding a good
teaching is building scaffolds
to um for every child to learn
sometimes you'll need a kind of rewards
to get things started
but there is an other element and that's
often overlooked we've all had teachers
that
teachers on subjects that we weren't
interested in but surprisingly we were
at by the end of the class because the
teacher he or himself was so passionate
about and passion can be very contagious
so
um try to be
motivated yourself show this try to also
explain why
you're motivated but also try to explain
why the child needs this because i have
to admit uh discussing my son
again as an example
i don't like anecdotes but i want to use
this to explain something is that um
well he i didn't convince him but he did
it because he thought well if my dad
thinks it's important it will probably
be important but later on he came to me
and said you were right i need this
and
sometimes you have to ask a kind of leap
of faith from your student or children
we know you i know it's hard now but
you'll get by and then you'll figure out
why you need this but
one last remark on this
if you don't know
why they need this
why your students need this and the only
answer is it's because it's in the
textbook or in the curriculum then
you're in deep trouble
because if you can't answer that
question how can you motivate your
children
that that
totally makes sense and sounds like a
good place to leave us on i could have
talked to you for much longer but we are
already at the end of our time today
thank you so much for joining us oh it
was great fun thank you
excellent and i want to again recommend
to everyone both the existing books on
urban myths in learning and education
and we look forward to your forthcoming
book as well
thank you and everyone have a great day
you